aujourd'hui le réchauffement climatique
impact en première en premier lieu l'eau
nous savons c'est la première victime de
ce réchauffement climatique qui de Isla
devient un enjeu extrêmement important
l'eau est un bien commun et je crois
qu'aujourd'hui ça devrait être une des
priorités de notre état alors bien sûr
nous avons fait une des auditions
pendant 6 mois pouvoir un petit peu la
situation actuelle sur notre territoire
et à partir de cela avec trois demi
collègues nous avons fait 8
préconisations alors aujourd'hui on a un
double phénomène d'une part les
infrastructures concernant l'eau sont à
la charge des communes qui doivent les
entretenir les rénover et aujourd'hui
les communes n'ont pas forcément les
moyens de faire ce travail or ce travail
est indispensable pour préserver la
quantité et la qualité de l'eau donc
aujourd'hui nous demandons et bien que
les agences de l'eau qui financent les
communes pour les infrastructures
récupère elles aussi les moyens qui
pourront ensuite être redonnés aux
communes pour entretenir ces systèmes on
doit apprendre on doit donner également
aux personnes et à l'agriculture qui est
la première consommatrice d'eau et bien
les moyens de d'apprendre à être plus
sobre il faut aller vers la sobriété
parce que je crois qu'aujourd'hui nous
n'avons pas le choix à prendre à
économiser l'eau apprendre à moins
polluer l'eau et donc voilà ce sont ces
préconisations que nous allons faire
aujourd'hui que nous avons fait dans
notre rapport que nous avons exposé et
je crois que à côté de la sobriété qui
est certainement le moyen le plus facile
d'économiser l'eau et bien il y a un
certain nombre de mesures qui pourront
être prises et il ne faut rien écarter
ni les retenues d'eau ni la réinjection
de l'eau dans les nappes ni la
réutilisation des eaux usées qui peuvent
être traitées ça se fait déjà dans
d'autres pays donc il ne faut rien
écarter et tout privilégié
[Musique]